so we can get started i have
an apology from councillor stuart any
other apologies for
leaving her no can i have uh
somebody move that we accept that
apology from councillor stuart
i'm going to set that apology andrea and
john
thank you very much all those in favor
say aye
aye those against that's karen any
conflicts of interest to declare
[Music]
[Applause]
right minutes from the last meeting
we've all had a look at them
anyone want to move that they'd be
accepted
i'll move the minutes accept management
thank you john right any discussion
around those
but i'll put that to the vote all those
in favor say aye
those against carried
right matters arising from those minutes
you've got something okay
yes i managed to get hold of james today
and clarified that it will be a
permanent site
he's planning on a permanent sign and
when the lifeguard
notice has expired or is complete
the welcome to pegasus fight will go
back on so you'll have a welcome to
pegasus side on each side that is the
proposal
um however they're still working through
it through with stuff
so there's some safety concerns and
various and some other things so he's
hoping it's going to get done before
january and us and then
if it happens we'll have a report in
february for the
landscaping yeah he's got a couple of
alternate sites that he can use for this
summer for the surf like it's for the
surf lifesaving club hours
so he has got a couple of alternate
sites
which aren't ideal now can i ask what
are the concerns
being that we are now in summer
why the delays um why is there a problem
apparently the reason why the original
sign was put
on the right hand side was because
the road turns quite sharply into the
circle and there was a bit of worry
about visibility and
sight lines and things like that so now
they're not sure if
putting another one there it's not going
to basically come to that
one but then james did mention that
having two up
might very well slow the traffic down
but it's for them to work through
so when we were surely not the new year
now when i spoke to them they were busy
dealing with it
two hospitals kathy graham
um in in kennedy kennedy
and um simon and joe and
yeah yeah sorry and the results from the
people yeah
so all of them have to agree with that
one sign
for seven by setting it's primarily
around the safety
surely the location i appreciate coming
up
put on the urgent sort of correct rather
than waiting till
after another jones seems quite
confident that it will go through
shortlist
and i spoke to him today yeah this sort
of seems silly that it's being
sort of discussed and discussed and like
just a matter of getting science put in
you don't have to muck around
it might be better to have one permanent
sign with
variable boards um like they have on the
outskirts of rangiora
that is what would be the absolute ideal
because we actually get
signs we actually get signs that are
placed illegally the
tucker sign is placed illegally the um
the kfc summer festival sign was placed
on road reserve where it shouldn't have
been it's been every sign is placed
where it shouldn't be so actually having
something where we could have that
would be the absolute ideal i would have
said perhaps this site could be
temporary next year we can look at some
more permanent structure for different
things
to go through but i guess my concern is
that we'll
come now to the end of the year for our
board meetings and we're not going to
see it potentially until the new year
which i am
encouraging us james has got plan b
about another location where he can
put it on somebody's fence plan b
not ideal the roading has suggested that
it should actually be on the road down
to the beach and
james had said well that's just
pointless because if you're already
going to the beginning
yeah and i agree with them that actually
needs to be
um and can i have no idea about
my feelings about this thinking
i think i'd like to move on um
sort of being delayed any longer well
kay's been dealing with with
trying to move it along so it has
it is trying to be dealt with yeah um
well i think it's pretty important
especially the summer's coming up
it is right any other matters arising
right no documentations and
presentations from the community
are during business no grant the pegasus
membership
come and tell us
good evening thank you and welcome to
the members from the pegasus adventure
sit here grant you'll keep him on track
so that's good
yes very well um so you'll recall that
last year myself and members of the
men she actually came to talk to
the community board i think it might
have been pre-covered just around the
fact that they wanted to move into
gladstone park
so we've been doing some work with them
to actually uh kind of progress that
along
are at a point now where they really
require a license to occupy
in order to allow them
to secure funding because obviously once
they've got that
the funders have a lot more confidence
in the fact that they're actually going
to have a
[Applause]
obviously we're aware of the the social
benefits that that kind of activity
provides
especially for our male
community members who sometimes should
be isolated
um really good initiatives that they
bring
um we have developed a plan for where
they would leave some great state park
which
we've seen the back of the report there
um
we've also put some terms in term uh
some terms
regarding release organization
um so that really kind of outlines some
of the things that we would be expecting
of the ninja
um derrick has just uh
informed me as well that they don't have
any nighttime activity
um so realistically in terms of noise
it's going to be
really minimal there's hardly anybody
that lives around here as well they'll
add another
facet of security to the park too um
so look from staff's perspective it's a
good use of the space
we're happy with the group like that
moving in they tend to take quite a bit
of ownership over
areas that they move into and they
legitimize a lot of activity that
happens around there as well
um so look i think it's really positive
that there's one um
actually services community i think
being on great stone park as well
there's an opportunity that they'll be
able to
entice people from wood end as well as
pegasus
and actually make that a bit of a
central hub there for people in the area
so look i'm i'm happy to take any
questions in regards to
anything that you might have in terms of
the license i'd like to ask a question
if i could
share
the power tools cannot be used after 2
20 30 that's 8 30 at night i presume
now it seems rather strange so that
buildings
there's not a residential property they
don't operate at night so it's a
standard
thing that we put in there but that's
not gonna that's not gonna happen
yeah because i i just felt that you know
that um
reading that some of these guys might
want to work through 10
30 you know at night and
you know with today's buildings with
their um
bats and soundproofing i just find that
way
um restrictive you know these guys once
they start talking and working they just
keep on going probably at 12 o'clock
that's been indicated to me they
wouldn't be working that way
yeah i mean is that a condition that the
community board wishes us to
review i'm i'm happy for the mention
it could be reviewed in the future if
there is an issue if there is a need or
whatever so i think it deletes you
they're happy at the moment are you
happy with that that the men she
you guys themselves are happy and if
they do need it
we could look at reviewing it at that
time perhaps they just use hand saws
after that
yeah the lights turned on
did you have a question mark no but i
want to remove it yeah
yeah could i just have one question that
is 4.12
about the the fencing so it is the
preference of the council
so preference what does it say so that's
to allow the
so that's to allow clubs some time
because events is obviously quite an
expense
and it's not where they probably want to
focus their funding so look it's a
preference of ours that we do actually
end up fencing it
um but just noting that probably not
going to happen immediately
but we would prefer something like that
to actually be instant secured and
number one to offer them some security
yeah um but obviously we wanted to be
see-through fencing so that people have
an idea as to what their
activity is and because there is uh
power tools and other things going on
it's a little bit of a work site
i guess we just want to make sure that
there's some visual separation into the
community
prices are just kind of charging so
toilet facilities would they be using
the ones in gladstone park yeah they
have assured me that they can
uh negotiate that pathway to those
spoilers
uh just bring you had a chance grant has
other users of the park been
insulted on this proposed activity yeah
look there's been a few conversations
with them the reality is that they're
probably going to support some of those
activities as well
um we haven't done specific fill in your
feedback consultation it's really just
been heads up here and there
but no we could certainly do more
conversation if that's something what
was going on
i just wanted it for the other users for
support
oh yeah look we haven't written down
um word for word but we've not had uh
i say that now we haven't had anybody
raise any concerns around it we don't
believe it's going to be a burden on a
car parking and
realistically where they are they
shouldn't be interfering with any other
group
so the gladstone advisory group would
tend to have members on it from a lot of
the maintenance
is actually part of that group as well
so he's the one that actually holds the
report together so
yeah mark did you want to yeah i'm happy
to move um
[Applause]
thank you john do you want to speak to
that mark look
at it
that's quite a big area yeah it's just
concerned that um
you know it's it's quite durable
i'm sure that you could um yeah it's
quite a bit of effect for money
which um you could get by with a lot
smaller area
um and still get the security around
that critical area which is the sheet
itself
and look we can always look at where the
finish line goes if that does become a
concern to them i guess the idea of
leasing or licensing that amount of area
to them
it allows a certain amount of
flexibility and kind of privatize this
space for them to
it's really to kind of create a visual
barrier but also a stock mechanism for
people so that they don't just change
straight through this
[Applause]
be that they utilise the the existing
carpark
right i think amount of tier i'd like
support the
recommendation and the motion um when
the eventually come to us last time i
think we actually would mention a
passing leg some
park may be a possible prospect for them
um and i know the main shed in kaiapo in
particular
and elsewhere are very popular and one
day i
two joining membership so i'm i'm quite
supportive of this and i think it'd be a
good time for them
and it's a very worthwhile organisation
[Applause]
is that council redmond declaring a
conflict
[Laughter]
um yeah i mean i'd just like to say that
yeah i mean i'm
very supportive of the men shed i think
gladstone park is a good location
i think the two communities what in
pegasus that provides the ideal
i think to stop waikoku you know
gentlemen
joining in as well which i think is
really good
and i congratulate the men's shed on on
securing funding
um at a very early stage you know in
your life
span so i think they've done extremely
well in securing that funding
and um certainly wish them on the best
so i'll put that to the vote with
something else all those in favor say
aye
those against that one's carried
farewell
[Applause]
if you guys want to stay very welcome
but if you want to leave
that's fine
thank you very much thank you thank you
correspondence we haven't got any um
the mayor did send a joint letter from
um
the chair of the kaiapoi to heavenly
community board and the william seven
community board to
nztea which was which was very good
which
you have received a copy of um
i don't think there's anything other
than that one right
my cheers report anybody got any
questions
around it i'll take it as being read
sounds like
just usual any questions
there was something i was going to do
write it down
um the other thing i actually
um in the liaison person on the pegasus
residence group and just to let you know
that roger rule who is a president of
the pegasus residence group
is stepping down from that position as
at the end of december
matt james will be the acting president
until the agm
roger is staying on on the committee and
on the
pegasus community centre subcommittee so
he's just decided it's the right time
for him
to step down as the president so
if i may make one sort of comment
the moment and i put them in touch with
an endurance
and don't come back a couple of times
they're adamant that there's a
there's a relatively simple solution
there to get to that
um you know that standard two um and so
they're working with some engineers at
the moment it's just encouraging i think
other people
will have some um views too so it's i
mean it's not
cheap it's not incredibly expensive but
um there's a there are a couple of
quite workable solutions to get to that
level too
and it's jared i think sort of alluded
to as well just
yes of interesting and that like it was
a good session and uh
just you know during the slide i did a
good job in terms of presenting some
information to us and then
taking back some feedback in terms of
how to move things along and quite a
quite difficult situation for them as
much as for us
um templin group had engaged a
contractor
to do some maintenance including
removing some of the weed around the
fringes of the lake
and the beaches not sure how the algal
bloom
impacts on that i haven't found that out
yet so
um but i mean i had asked it goes back
to september when i
had first raised it with them around
with temporary group around the wheat in
the lake
um and then it's taken until now to
actually
do anything so and right by the way in
the comment this guy at the conference
those two little two little solar bees
that flop around the lake
i mean they're designed for kind of
swimming pool size lakes
you know we're talking about something
that's massively they're very good in
their own right don't get me wrong
but the scale is just completely out of
whack so
um
i mean it is affecting recreationally i
mean the dragon boatings yeah that's had
to be cancelled the
um
the waka armor everything even the model
yachts
are not sailing for algae toxic algae so
it is affecting recreational why is it
lifesaving training
serve life-saving training
um so i'd like to move that my report be
accepted
do i have a second up thank you john any
other discussion around that
write all those in favor say hi close
again
right matters for information
anybody got any questions around any of
the reports anything that they might
have read or
seen
all right would somebody like to move
that we received the information and the
reports
yeah thank you andrew do i have a
senator for that
thank you mark any discussion around
that
all right all those in favor say aye all
right those against
that's karen members information
exchange john you put in a report thank
you very much
nothing bad it's good mark
barbecue tomorrow for school which we
probably should have done that um
communicated out that came very fast so
we've um
copy new world is pretty much sponsoring
it so we are doing what we did last year
for the honey but not to that scale so
if anyone wants to go they're more than
welcome
so it's 11 30 at community centre and
then 12 30 in the rick wrap and the
wreck
for kappa haka and
something else jump jam and
then a community barbecue which we're
just having like hamburgers and
which was it was quite amazing too we
put a grant which we didn't get
and then said that they would sponsor it
pretty much the whole lot
which was cool because it was um it was
in such a short it didn't really get
funding like that
so easy and so quick it just shows you
that there are business in the community
that want to be engaged so
sorry i communicated that but it was we
only sent the communication out on
friday to the tunisia session so
it's been a bit rushed so it's an invite
to board members
thank you join in jump jam yeah
[Music]
but yeah
[Applause]
champions championships and they're
representing the south
and the nationals so there's a pretty
good top 10
crew that are going to be dancing yeah
that was good coming up and down gently
andrew um
nothing much before i just go to the
pieces um northern pieces paid advisor
group meeting so we had another good
meeting sort of um
really making some progress there and as
a major uh review which happens
next year i think it is so um council
will get organised
around that but um yeah i think it's
been a
um there's been good progress made there
over the last couple years just slowing
edging forward and getting some good
information together when that review
comes about we'll
be better placed than we were three
years ago
um i've tabled my report saying yep i
won't
council committees in particular
clean review and dnr has been maybe very
regular
so it's been very busy so um these are
just other things that um
the grand christchurch workshops were
quite interesting
and i need to bring some statistics
along that i
didn't got those so i won't talk to
those
um but we're part of the greater
christchurch
group which includes us uh christchurch
and salva so it's been quite a threesome
to go to those
nations i'm sitting next to a
woman from the airport they had a whole
mix of people
and i said to her you're really going to
open an airport in towns
and uh she was quite confident and
brought in 10 years i'd have an airport
there they've got to start working on it
all the time so that was quite
interesting to hear that
from the source
[Applause]
so that's it for me that's what i'm just
reading the community service awards
which
i'm sorry that she slipped my mind
slightly um liz joe who came to see us
around the
road naming in ravenswood she received a
community service award for her wreck
with um
writing for the disabled and philip read
the um
citation which was really good and
[Applause]
this month because we're actually going
to be hiring a
full-time manager so it's actually been
working with hr
and trying to establish a new role which
has been quite a big bodywork and
very grateful for um tessa and wendy
howe
um they've been working quite closely so
that's been quite taxing
um thank you to the mayor um brent and i
had checked from
outside the meeting that was australian
we're looking forward to
working with them here and getting
just some feedback and some constructive
feedback through
yeah yeah so we'll see how that will be
the new year
yeah and you went along with two hats to
the um
cookie beach oh yeah yeah that's right
with the um
it was lovely it was really quick
with the place and also as um maybe
never support
and also now that was really positive it
was good it was good turn out
yeah did you get much interest from them
yeah we just got five sign-ups tonight
which
was just three months to be street
coordinators which is fantastic
so yeah very very great yes anything
happening with the health advisory group
no we've got cancer
yeah they've been holding them by
so
[Applause]
to be honest with you after covert it
sort of went a bit quiet because of so
many other groups and
we are sort of expanded on that into
other a lot of covered
well uh the welfare um today so
i'm sure we'll reconnect again but there
is a few gaps there from people moving
on
yeah not literally moving on but um
but yeah yeah yeah
right consultation projects what do we
got the
discretionary grant um 304
and landscaping fun we've still got some
money so at some point
sort of yeah march we'll probably have
to meet again and actually talk about
the landscaping
fund and how we want to spend the
remainder of that one
problem
sorry that's a good point actually can
you put it down for the february
um
yep so we've approved that one so that's
fine um
yes but there's a few other projects we
sort of had on the list that
we were going to go back and revisit
those other signs the two other signs
that we approved
of those ones you were talking about
though no the woody beach sign we
approved the welcome to wedding
it's like going to the coldest castle
most of the locals actually like it
because i want people
[Applause]
some of the local residents would like
more right media items
i'll come up with something that'll be a
short
short thing no questions understanding
orders and no
urgent changes it may as you would have
seen on that
amazing facebook page
people talking about the algae have we
actually put anything from
us yeah no i haven't
not not sure i'm not drawing in on that
yeah
but as in our own one yeah yeah
right um
[Applause]
normally we've never needed a function i
realized there'll be pranks but
um just to say thank you for all the
work that the board has done throughout
the last 12 months it's been
a year like no other really um but i
just want to
enhance the council acknowledge uh how
strong this board is
and all your advocacy that you do i'm
forever impressed with
the work that shane does as chair
actually
all the work that she puts into writing
submissions and advocacy and i know
others of you also contributing out
there but particularly your chair
superb governance manager
just briefly to say thank you and wish
you all a
very merry christmas and a happy new
year and look forward to
continuing to work with you in the new
year we have achieved
a lot this last year and even it's
available through woody
that's been over a number of years
actually which has led to
the state crossing as well so um in the
new year um
shona and i both came to law although to
the minister
new minister of transport around um
um building bypass related meters which
we talked about so
some great projects that we'll
thank you very much for all of you do
appreciate it
and i'd just like to say thank you to um
all the board members
um and councillor stewart who's not here
um yeah i mean all your contributions
you know they're absolutely great
they're ready to do out in the community
um you know talking to members of the
community bringing that feedback
back is really really important um
definitely thank you to courtney for
she's um
you've done well yeah we've trained you
well
in the minutes and she's doing really
well we have to see you for
morning tea on the 10th i believe yes
into k uh governance person who has
stood by us and worked our way through
us and
simon who's not here as a manager this
year
so um i understand we may be getting a
new manager so
we'll head on to our fourth manager
that's yet to be determined by jim
towards the end of january so
we'll have that sorted one way or
another in general
comes along to the meetings um and he
has done a lot of advocacy work
for our area around we can look at the
lake we can look at wood end
safety improvements we can look at the
wooden bypass
all of those things so the mayor has
done a lot of advocacy work for this
area and
um i think on behalf of the board i'd
like to say we really
really do appreciate that so thank you
very much
and on that note on to sarah
we haven't seen you for a while you
haven't come a long time meeting for a
while
um but yeah i mean she looks after the
whole governance area
and um is very very good at that one i'd
and we said at least do something safely
did they
come directly out that's something that
was before
the big announced back in through march
they said that meaning that that was
already going out for
tender and then be to be completed by a
beginning school champion and the next
three things i believe are the
or the roundabout here the traffic
lights at the next i just want to make
sure that because they don't
you know after pushing them they did say
that and will we get acknowledged for
that
no i could say
[Laughter]
meeting we are at the waikoku beach
community hall on tuesday the 9th of
february and note it is the tuesday
because of
waitangi does it see you
then now members now members
now members now members in